die nato verstärkt ihre truppen
überall im osten europas
auch die ostsee zum krisengebiet die
deutsche marine ist gefordert
spannungen an der ostflanke haben
zugenommen erst recht nach russlands
überfall auf die ukraine
großmanöver waren jahrzehntelang
geschichte jetzt finden sie wieder statt
stehen wir vor einem neuen kalten krieg
ja ich würde sogar sagen kalter krieg
2.0
der kalte krieg auf denen wir zu steuern
zumindest ich denke dass wir darauf zu
steuern ist komplexer als der kalte
krieg den ich jetzt zum beispiel nicht
mehr erlebt habe
seit einigen jahren kommt es immer
wieder zu gefährlichen zwischenfällen
zwischen nato flugzeugen und russischen
fliegern
es kann zu fehlkalkulationen und zur
falschen reaktionen kommen zum anderen
zwischen nato und russland auch zwischen
nato und russland denn wir werden ja die
kräfte im die nato wird ja die kräfte an
der ostflanke nun erheblich verstärkt
deutschland steht vor enormen
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
es wird viel geld für seine streitkräfte
aus geben dieses geld darf nicht
verloren gehen deutschland rüstet wieder
auf 100 milliarden euro für die
bundeswehr stehen bereit die nato ist im
alarmzustand
schafft das sicherheit
mitte märz 2022
wir fahren zu einem der strategischen
brennpunkte nach norwegen für russische
atom u boote mit
interkontinentalraketen ist das
seegebiet dort ein wichtiges
operationsgebiet
norwegen und damit die nato grenzt
direkt an putins russland
3000 kilometer entfernt von deutschland
30.000 soldaten und soldatinnen aus 27
nato staaten nehmen an diesem manöver
teil
eines der größten seit dem kalten krieg
[Musik]
das gelände ist unwegsam aber dennoch
von strategischer bedeutung
die bundeswehr ist auch dabei
deutsche gebirgsjäger sichern die küste
in norwegen ist die regierung schon
länger alarmiert immer häufiger werden
russische kriegsschiffe gesichtet
diesen norwegischen schützenpanzer fährt
aber verändert der krieg in der ukraine
ihre situation
wir schauen da schon hin wegen der
gemeinsamen grenze mit russland kennen
wir die bedrohung
das ist nichts neues
klar die situation in der ukraine hat
auswirkungen aber unser training hat
sich nicht geändert
[Musik]
der kommandeur der norwegischen
streitkräfte setzt auf waffen aber auch
auf kontakte mit dem russischen militär
ich habe mit dem kommandeur der
russischen nordflotte gesprochen und ihm
den defensiven charakter dieser übung
erklärt die nato hat keine offensiv
pläne das ist eine übung um den norden
norwegens zu verteidigen dispo offenheit
und transparenz sind sehr bedeutend um
fehlentscheidungen zu verhindern
[Musik]
viele entscheidungen das könnte echte
gefechte zur folge haben und
schlimmstenfalls zu einem krieg führen
in deutschland sehen experten große
risiken an der ostsee deshalb ist auch
die bundesmarine gefordert strandbad
warnemünde ein deutsches marineschiff
läuft aus an vielen tagen sind auf der
ostsee fast mehr kriegsschiffe als
kreuzfahrtschiffe unterwegs die ostsee
ist eine wichtige handelsroute und damit
von strategischer bedeutung
sie ist weltweit einer der wichtigsten
tanker routen für rohöl besonders für
russland
putin exportiert einen großen teil
seines rohöls über die ostsee
russische kriegsschiffe sollen den
seeweg schützen 2009 10 gab es russische
flotten manöver nie gekannter größe auch
vor der deutschen ostseeküste auf see
auch schiffe die nukleare waffen
abfeuern können
wir sprechen mit der vorsitzenden des
verteidigungsausschusses des bundestages
über die strategische bedeutung der
ostsee die ostsee ist natürlich ein sehr
wichtiges mehr weil sie auch von
russland genutzt wird und auch die
chinesen sind dort präsent mit den
russen zusammen also nicht umsonst ist
auch im zuge der des ukrainischen
konfliktes einige
marineeinheiten verlegt worden vom
mittelmeer in die ostsee um eben zu
schauen was sich da tut naja ein
mögliches szenario dass es ein
angriffskrieg über die ostflanke europas
gibt auch übers meer
das ist das szenario was wir
grundsätzlich an der grenze zu russland
haben sowohl über das meer als auch über
land und letztendlich auch aus der luft
besorgt schaut man auch im hamburger
institut für friedensforschung auf die
ostsee das anerkannte unabhängige
institut erforscht die bedingungen von
frieden und sicherheit in europa
manöver im ostseeraum heißt wir werden
chips manöver unterstützt von
lufteinheiten sehen sowohl auf nato
seite als auch auf russischer seite die
ostsee ist jetzt kein sonderlich großes
gebiet und ich vermute dass es dort auch
immer wieder zu zwischenfällen kommen
wird wo sich dann beispielsweise
russische flieger und nato flieger
relativ nahe kommen werden wo vielleicht
auch natur luftraum verletzt wird solche
vorfälle haben sich schon ereignet
bilder von 2020
zwei russische flieger im nahbereich
eines us kriegsschiffes über der ostsee
gefilmt aus einem nato kampfjet
gefährliche begegnungen
unter umständen kann es nach einer
solchen situation sehr schnell sehr
brenzlig werden beispielsweise wenn es
zu einem unfall kommt in dem moment wo
beispielsweise russische kampfflieger
nato territorium verletzten steigen
üblicherweise nato kampfflieger auf und
eskortieren dann friedlich die
russischen flieger aus dem eigenen
luftraum raus wenn ein solches manöver
von russischer seite missverstanden wird
könnte es unter umständen sein
feuergefecht kommen es könnte dazu
kommen dass ein oder zwei maschinen
abgeschossen werden und dann müssen die
militärs und die politiker relativ
schnell diesen vorfall aufklären
oberst der bundeswehr wolfgang richter
kennt die risiken
auch früher habe es brenzlige
situationen gegeben
wir müssen alle einen kühlen kopf
behalten ich hoffe dass das auch die
russische seite tut denn wir haben schon
einmal 2015 an der syrischen grenze
gesehen dass ein russisches flugzeug von
türkischen abfangjägern abgeschossen
worden ist das ist aber gelungen zu
deeskalieren wir haben jetzt viel mehr
dichte im luftraum oder damit solche
solche zwischenfälle passieren können
und das heißt wir brauchen jetzt auch
mechanismen um solche zwischenfälle zu
verhindern und wenn es dann nicht
verhindert werden kann sofort zu
deeskalieren
damit das gelingt müssen beide seiten
immer im gespräch bleiben zumal die
atomaren waffenarsenale über die sowohl
russland wie auch die nato verfügen die
situation zusätzlich gefährlich machen
beispiel kaliningrad die russische
exklave liegt zwischen polen und litauen
beides nato staaten
in kaliningrad stehen iskander raketen
sie können auch nukleare sprengköpfe
tragen ihre reichweite fast bis berlin
oder gar weiter
der einsatz von so genannten taktischen
nuklearwaffen könnte einen dritten
weltkrieg auslösen fürchten experten
auch ehemalige verteidigungsminister
sind besorgt die sich in einem european
leadership netzwerk zusammengeschlossen
haben die sicherheits expertin julia
berghof verarbeitet für dieses
beratergremium ich halte die lage für
sehr dramatisch sehr gefährlich ich
glaube nicht dass wir kurz vor einem
nuklearkrieg stehen aber ich denke wenn
wir so weitermachen wie bisher in den
nächsten jahren dann werden sich die
risiken oder das risiko dass wir
tatsächlich auf eine nukleare
konfrontation zu steuern signifikanter
wenn
hans christensen gilt als einer der
besten kenner russische atomwaffen
weltweit wie schätzt er putins nukleare
drohungen ein würde der russische
präsident wirklich den befehl erteilen
atomwaffen in der ukraine einzusetzen
zurzeit ist das wohl eher rhetorisch
aber es stimmt
wenn es zu einem einsatz von atomwaffen
kommt dann werden es taktische
nuklearwaffen seien glaube ich
ein anderes beispiel sie zünden eine
atomwaffe über dem offenen meer
und vorstellbar wäre eine über dem
schwarzen meer oder über der nordsee
oder der ostsee
aber das wäre ein signal
man würde nicht darauf abzielen etwas zu
zerstören oder menschen zu töten aber es
wäre ein dramatisches signal
test schuss einer iskander-raketen
bilder vom russischen militär
nukleare abschreckung bedeutet der
gegner darf sich nie sicher sein ob die
raketen eingesetzt werden oder nicht
[Musik]
satellitenbilder vom baum russischer
speziallager aus dem jahr 2021 in einem
spannungsvoll wird hier atom munition
zwischengelagert laut informationen aus
nato-kreisen waren anfang märz hier
keine atomsprengköpfe gelagert ich wäre
mehr besorgt wenn taktischen
nuklearwaffen aus dem zentralen lagern
die sind ja nicht bei den verbänden aus
den zentralen lagern herausgeholt werden
das sehen wir aber nicht also es gibt
keine indikation darüber würde ich denke
wir werden das feststellen wenn
taktischen nuklearwaffen aus diesem
lager geholt werden putin verfügt über
geschätzt fast 2000 taktische atomwaffen
die für den einsatz auf dem gefechtsfeld
vorgesehen sind
das sind atomwaffen die begrenzte
zerstörungen anrichten können abgeworfen
werden sie aus flugzeugen oder mit
raketen abgeschossen
die nato verfügt in europa über 150
solcher us-atombomben auch für flugzeuge
der bundeswehr die in der eifel
stationiert sind
england und frankreich haben sogenannte
strategische atomwaffen in ihren
arsenalen das sind waffen mit einer
großen reichweite und einer größeren
zerstörungskraft russland und die usa
haben ebenfalls solche waffen
die atomwaffen depots sind gut gefüllt
auf beiden seiten und auch die
bundeswehr die über keine eigenen
atomwaffen verfügt übt regelmäßig den
kampf unter atomaren und chemischen
bedingungen
nach dem ersten überfall der russen auf
die ukraine im jahr 2014 reagierte auch
die
nato-truppen wurden zu manövern an die
ostgrenze zu russland verlegt auch die
bundeswehr nahm schon 2018 an einem
manöver in litauen teil
sie üben die abwehr eines angriffs roth
verteidigt blau greift an
derzeit sind rund 900 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten in litauen
stationiert der von der bundeswehr
geführte nato verband verfügt über
insgesamt 1600 männer und frauen aus
mehreren staaten das problem die kleinen
baltischen staaten haben wenig militär
litauen ist über land nur über einen
schmalen korridor zu erreichen den kann
russland leicht sperren russische
luftabwehrraketen beherrschen dann den
luftraum
[Musik]
gegen die ukraine führt russland einen
angriffskrieg auch im norden europas auf
der ostsee und im baltikum gibt es
zunehmend spannungen zwischen nato und
russland und es gibt eine neue nukleare
bedrohungslage eine gewaltige
herausforderung für die nato und damit
auch für die bundeswehr
es sind schwierige strategische fragen
vor denen unsere politik steht
diskutiert wurde das bislang nur wenig
drei tage nach dem angriff auf die
ukraine hat bundeskanzler scholz eine
schnelle antwort es gibt mehr geld für
die bundeswehr
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
der bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten die mittel
werden wir für notwendige investitionen
rüstungsvorhaben nutzen wir werden von
nun an jahr für jahr mehr als zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts und
unsere verteidigung in bisher
mehr geld für waffen selbst die grünen
und auch die fdp unterstützen das
[Musik]
bundeswehr ist sie jahrzehntelang unter
gespart wurden und runter gespart heißt
auch nicht mehr investiert wurden in
kasernen in den bestand aber schon jetzt
bekommt die bundeswehr jährlich mehr als
45 milliarden euro überwiesen
[Musik]
trotzdem leidet die truppe unter
ausrüstungsmängel beispiel der neue
schützenpanzer puma seine fertigstellung
verzögerte sich um jahre die kosten
explodierten immerhin demnächst soll er
einsatzbereit sein wenn er schießt und
nicht gerade wieder repariert werden
muss
hans peter bartels war bis 2020
wehrbeauftragter des bundestages vor
allem seine berichte offenbarten dass
ausrüstungs desaster und daran habe sich
nicht viel geändert sagt er heute ich
das her hat überall lücken sie müssen zu
100 prozent ausgestattet sein also wir
müssen alles was sie brauchen also von
schützenpanzern über nachtsichtgeräte
bis hin zur bodengebundenen
flugabwehr nächst bereichs schutz gegen
drohnen gegen hubschrauber
jetzt schnell aus gewusst wenn nicht bis
2031 sondern das muss dieses jahr
anfangen
eine showveranstaltung der bundeswehr
eigentlich hat sie zwei panzerdivision
doch wegen reparaturstau und mängel
aller art sehe die wirklichkeit anders
aus die bundeswehr sei immer noch nur
bedingt einsatzbereit
dafür brauchen sie dann pro division
etwa drei kampfbrigaden eine brigade hat
5 6000 soldaten und wenn wir heute
schauen was kriegt die bundeswehr
zusammen für die nato dann ist schon bei
der stellung einer einzigen brigade für
die narbe response force das limit
erreicht auch diese brigade muss sich
dann in allen anderen truppenteilen des
heeres material manchmal auch personal
ausland also eine brigade nicht voll
aufstellen zu können wenn man eigentlich
acht bis zehn zugesagt hat bis 2031 voll
einsatzbereit auszurüsten und
aufzustellen dann ist das wenig mitte
märz in norwegen beim nato manöver hier
gibt es schon seit sechs jahren moderne
schützenpanzer
die kanone ist zuverlässig und trifft
präzise sehr modern und effizient
norwegen hat hightech daneben auch altes
gerät das sei aber kein problem
es ist doch mein job dass das was da ist
funktioniert ich muss doch in eine krise
ziehen mit dem was ich habe und nicht
mit dem was ich mir wünsche das
wichtigste ist doch der soldat wie er
mit der ausrüstung umgeht und wie wir
das managen dass sie wirkt
perfekt auto
deutsches management sieht anders aus
zeitweise waren beispielsweise 2019 alle
sechs u boote der marine kaputt nichts
ging mehr dass er jetzt wohl besser
geworden sagen uns experten
6 u boote klingt wenig ist aber immer
noch mehr als andere staaten an der
ostsee haben
ein trauerspiel sei auch die
einsatzbereitschaft der fast 40 jahre
alten tornado flieger bei den neuen
eurofightern sehe es besser aus sagen
experten
details sind mittlerweile geheim es war
wohl peinlich
woran liegt der schlechte
ausrüstungsstand der bundeswehr
es ist nicht nur eine frage des geldes
ist eine frage der beschaffungs
beschaffungsprozesse sind komplex vor
allem wenn man alles europaweit
ausschreibt das dauert dann immer wieder
in der kritik das bundesamt für
beschaffung in koblenz ein
behördenapparat mit vielen vorschriften
erlassen und regeln mitunter vergehen
jahre bis neue anschaffungen die truppe
erreichen immer wieder wurde in der
vergangenheit versucht die behörde
effizienter zu machen doch fast alle
bemühungen scheiterten
jetzt unternimmt die neue
bundesregierung einen erneuten versuch
will die beschaffung beschleunigen
experten bleiben skeptisch
denn eines steht für viele feste mehr
geld allein sei auch keine lösung für
die bundeswehr sie hatte zuletzt 47
milliarden euro aus dem bundeshaushalt
bekommen das ist ja nicht nichts mehr
hören aber immer wieder dass
beispielsweise die bundeswehr im
beschaffungswesen das geld gar nicht
ausgeben kann das heißt wir haben es
hier letztlich mit formen von
missmanagement zu tun dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium und auch
direkt bei der bundeswehr und diese form
von missmanagement die muss spätestens
jetzt enden denn man kann ja nicht
einfach jetzt 100 milliarden auf ein
nicht funktionierendes system drauf
gießen und hoffen dass es dadurch besser
wird das wird das
verteidigungsministerium auch sehr
schnell so organisieren müssen dass
dieses geld nicht nicht verbrannt wird
in einfach nur teuren projekten sondern
wirklich da angelegt wird wo die not am
größten ist wo die lücken am größten
sind und wo sofort wirksam ein effekt
erzielt wird doch wie konnte es soweit
kommen 16 jahre stellte die cdu alle
verteidigungsminister ihre partei in der
regierungsverantwortung hat auch die
verteidigungsminister gestellt und
trotzdem hat das nicht funktioniert weil
wir nicht leider nicht allein regiert
haben stand immer auch im wahlprogramm
von cdu und csu dass zwei prozent sehen
muss eingehalten werden und im grunde
ist das dann leider immer gescheitert am
koalitionspartner an der spd wer dazu
nicht bereit war dabei wurden reformen
von allen verschlafen und es waren cdu
csu verteidigungsminister unter denen
der bundeswehr mittel gekürzt wurden
seit 2018 gibt es ein neues
fähigkeitsprofil der bundeswehr
darin steht was sich die bundeswehr
vorgenommen hat sie will ihre aufgaben
in der landes- und bündnisverteidigung
wieder bestmöglich erfüllen heißt es
unter anderem solle eine zusätzliche
dritte panzerdivision aufgestellt werden
reichen 100 milliarden euro für diese
pläne überhaupt aus damit würde man ein
großteil dieses fähigkeitsprofil es dann
schon finanzieren können aber nicht das
ganze frieden das alte fähigkeitsprofil
von 2018 aber das problem ist dass sich
die zeit inzwischen weiterentwickelt hat
man bräuchte wohl bis zu 200 milliarden
euro und den anforderungen der nato zu
genügen sagen experten fast das doppelte
des geplanten sondervermögens sicher ist
das sondervermögen klingt besser als es
ist rund 50 milliarden mehr waren
ohnehin für die kommenden jahre schon
eingeplant die neue
verteidigungsministerin hat viel zu tun
mit
dem anstieg der militärausgaben auf zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
steigt der deutsche verteidigungs etat
auf rund 75 milliarden euro jährlich
damit wären wir nach ausgaben die
drittstärkste militärmacht der welt nach
den usa china und noch vor russland
das sondervermögen ist ein schnellschuss
viele mängel bei der truppe sind
hausgemacht viel geld wurde schon in den
zurückliegenden jahren ausgegeben ohne
dass sich der zustand der bundeswehr
wirklich verbesserte
ohne weitere konzepte droht der kühne
plan zum rohrkrepierer zu werden
eines der wichtigsten projekte für eine
moderne armee sei der bau von neuen
kampfflugzeugen und panzern sagt die
bundesregierung experten entgegnen das
geld müsse auch für andere rüstungsgüter
ausgegeben werden so sieht das auch ein
hoher polnischer nato-befehlshaber schon
2019 mahnte er mehr panzer allein wäre
nicht die beste lösung
da wir unsere truppen in der
vergangenheit abgebaut haben brauchen
wir einige neue fähigkeiten aber ich
denke nicht an die anzahl der kann
ich denke an das was wir zuerst verloren
haben pionier einheiten elektronische
kriegsführung aufklärung während für
flüsse
wenn wir unsere streitkräfte wieder
aufbauen sollte das nicht eine kopie der
vergangenheit seien
keine kopie der vergangenheit bedenkt
man dass auch im
verteidigungsministerium
eine debatte was die bundeswehr wirklich
braucht sei nötig sagt die vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses
wir brauchen vor allem modernen stahl
und einsatzbereiten start aber wir
brauchen darüber hinaus auch in dem
ganzen bereich cyber innovation
wissen wir vieles tun weil die angriffe
laufen nicht nur konventionell von denen
wir übrigens geglaubt haben sowas
passiert nicht mehr sollen sie laufen
eben auch über kommunikation und
administration auch der krieg
digitalisiert sich und wird moderne und
das wissen wir und wir müssen
entsprechend schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen
moderne waffen gibt es jetzt schon eine
cherilyn panzerabwehrrakete einmal
abgefeuert findet sie selbsttätig
erzielen
aber es gibt auch noch vieles was
dringend besser werden muss insider
berichten uns zieht die bundeswehr ins
manöver stört sie alle anderen nato
truppen mit ihren alten funkgeräten wenn
die bundeswehr zieht müssen die anderen
ihren funk abschalten stimmt das das ist
richtig und das ist ein gutes beispiel
dafür wie gespart wurde und wie dringend
notwendig tatsächlich dieses 100
milliarden projektes
ein besserer funk eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit den es schon
längst geben müsste mängel gibt es aber
auch bei anderen nato partnern
auch großbritannien kann nach einer
studie von 2015 nur eine brigade an die
ostflanke schicken
ähnlich sieht es in frankreich aus und
das obwohl seit jahren milliarden in die
rüstung fließen
russland gibt jährlich 56 milliarden
euro für seine verteidigung aus die
europäischen nato-staaten aber schon das
fünffache rund 306 milliarden
mit den usa sind es 1000 68 milliarden
das ist eine menge ließe sich da nicht
mit noch mehr kooperation viel geld
einsparen
[Applaus]
auch bei den waffengattungen sieht es
ähnlich aus
insgesamt hat die nato mehr soldaten
mehr panzer mehr schiffe und mehr
flugzeuge als russland aber eben nicht
überall und oft nicht koordiniert das
kann zu problemen führen
ein beispiel ein nato-manöver in litauen
eine flussüberquerung über die weichsel
wird gibt die bundeswehr pioniere sind
schnell alles funktioniert nur die us
kavallerie mit ihren radpanzern lässt
stunden auf sich warten
abstimmungsprobleme unter den
verbündeten im ernstfall darf so etwas
nicht passieren denn nur gemeinsam ist
die nato stark und ohne die amerikaner
läuft nach wie vor so gut wie gar nichts
sollte es dazu kommen dann müssten die
amerikaner
den europäern sehr stark aus helfenden
europa hat momentan nicht die
integrierten streitkräfte um russland
viel entgegensetzen zu können
seit einigen wochen verstärkt die nato
ihre ostflanke mit truppen
flugzeuge auch deutsche nach litauen und
rumänien
eine leichte us rat panzerbrigade
ebenfalls nach rumänien
in zukunft ca 2030 würden auch drei
deutsche panzerdivisionen hinzu kommen
so die planung
deutschland wäre dann die wichtigste
militärmacht im osten
die nato länder geben viel geld aus und
haben trotzdem schwächen gute planung
und die richtigen strategischen
entscheidungen sind nötig da sind die
politiker gefordert denn geld allein
reicht nicht eine gewaltige aufgabe für
nato und bundeswehr und vor allem für
die politik
[Applaus]
denn nur mit mehr waffen allein ist die
sicherheit europas auf dauer nicht zu
gewährleisten
trotz aller defizite und mängel die es
bei der bundeswehr und auch bei den
anderen nato streitkräften gibt eine
neue rüstungsspirale wäre teuer und
gefährlich
der verhandlungstisch scheint deshalb
fielen ähnlich wichtig zu sein wie die
forderung nach neuen waffen
[Musik]
es ist sicher richtig dass man die
ukraine militärisch nicht alleine lässt
und ich glaube es ist leider auch nötig
dass man putin eine gewisse militärische
bereitschaft oder eine gewisse stärke
zeigt weil das offensichtlich eine
sprache ist die die putin versteht also
wir müssen den militär zu militärdialog
stärken wir müssen diplomatische kanäle
offen halten so schwierig das auch
momentan sein mag spätestens dann wenn
die nato beginnt an der ostflanke massiv
aufzurüsten wäre sehr gut beraten sich
ihrer eigenen geschichte eines doppelten
ansatzes zu erinnern und zu sagen wir
rüsten auf aber gleichzeitig
unterbreiten wie ein dialogangebot an
die russische seite und dieses
dialogangebot das muss die
rüstungskontrolle sein und was immer die
zukunft bringt wir müssen wieder in
rüstungskontrolle kommen wir brauchen
wieder verträge unter den ländern so
dass wir gemeinsam sozusagen von diesem
voraus diesem aus diesem wettstreit
rauskommen das ist ganz elementar und
das werden wir in einer nacht putin ära
auch umgehend angehen müssen und werden
das auch weil frieden in europa wird es
ohne russland nicht geben
die bundeswehr und mit ihr die ganze
nato ist gefordert im umgang mit
aggressoren muss stärke gezeigt werden
dafür braucht die bundeswehr modernes
gerät auch wenn es viel geld kostet aber
das geld muss effektiv ausgegeben werden
und eines sollte man auf keinen fall
vergessen waffen allein sicher nicht den
frieden